leafcutter ants farm and eat fungus in  underground nests their colonies harvest  around 150 kilograms of plant matter  every year to feed their fungus crop to  understand how the ants turn leaves into  so much fungus food scientists film  their behavior in the lab they found  that leaf cutter ants have prehensile  leg tips which they use to delicately  grasp and manipulate leaves as they cut  them into tiny fragments these dexterous  tips are more flexible than non  prehensile ones allowing a precision  grip the team calculated that the ants  must cut nearly 3 kilometers of leaf  edge to process one square meter of  plant matter putting leaf cutter ants  near the limit of their energy budget  but the ants minimize their work by  choosing smaller leaves and feeding them  to the fungus as fragments rather than  pulp the ants prehensile leg tips help  them harvest food for their fungus crop  more efficiently giving them one leg up  in getting fungus from farm to table